.
In this presentation, I want to see more questions
Which deals with graphical representations of lines
We have a gym here
An offer to new members
Members can register by paying a subscription fee
$ 200 monthly installment
This is the registration
Registration
How much does this registration cost the member
At the end of the year?
So let 's find the equation determined
The amount of amount we will pay
p = Amount of amount to be paid
Against membership
If it does not matter how many months we will be participating in the sports club, all we care about is that when
To subscribe to the club, we have to pay $ 200 registration fee
I'll write - everything we'll assume will be in dollars -
If I write $ 200
Then we will have to pay $ 39 for each month
We share the club
If we take the number of months that
We share it and hit it with 39
They noticed that if we stayed there for one month, we would have to pay 1
Month x $ 39
We paid $ 200 as registration fees
If we have paid $ 239
If we stay two months, we pay $ 200 registration fee
Then pay 39 × 2, how much is equal?
Approximately 78
If the total amount is $ 278
All this is considered as linear associations
As graphic representations, let us represent this relationship
Remember that the graphical representation of a line can be y
= mx + b
This is one model, so we put this line in this picture or
By equation with this image, we can rearrange 39m and
200 and we get p = 39m + 200
What is the slope and y intersection?
Maybe you'll bother and say, there's x here
And y, but now we deal with p and m
Just remember that this variable is independent of this
The dependent variable
Here this is the independent variable
How many months?
We choose a number for the month and I will tell you what it is
The total value of the membership amount
The same
This is as x
This is as y
Using the similarity pattern, this
- We can say that it is the vertical intersection or the intersection of p
Or - I almost say cross y
But we actually intersect with the axis of p instead of
Axis y here
This is the tendency
Let us represent this pairing graphically
I will not paint it very accurately
Because I want to draw it manually
So you realize the idea
We can say it in the first quarter
We will not have bad months and the sports club
Will not pay us money
Here on the right, will
We pay $ 200 to the sports club
$ 200 vs. 0 Months
Then for each month, we'll
Pay $ 39 extra
If the inclination is 39
Suppose this is one month
This is months
This is for months
This axis is the price, pivot p
This intersection of P or
Intersection y
If it counts one month, how much will we pay?
Well, the tilt is 39, if we move one month forward
We will have to move up by 39
If here, that would be 239
If we move for another month, it will be 278
The naming of these axes is strange, but I do
I think you got the idea
If the graphic representation of the cost per month will look like
So
The question was how much each member would cost
At the end of the year?
12 Months
We have to go 2, 3, all this way until we get to 12 months
Which will be here
Then the graphic representation will be somewhere here
But we can find it algebraically
At the end of the year, m will be 12
When m = 12, how much would it cost?
Membership cost will be $ 200
Registration fee + 39 × number
Months, i x 12
How much does it cost 39 × 12?
2 × 9 = 18
2 × 3 = 6, + = 70
I have 0
1 × 9 = 9
1 x 3 - We want to ignore this
1 x 3 = 3
If we have 8
7 + 9 = 16
1 + 3 = 4
If the membership cost is $ 200 + 39 × 12
= $ 468
If it equals $ 468 at the end of the year
If we went all this way to 12, we would have to appoint
668 somewhere here on the line, if
We continued to go
Let us solve more of these issues
Bobby and Petra are holding a lemon juice stall and paying
$ 0.45 per cup lemon juice
$ 0.45 per cup
To achieve a point, they must collect $ 25
How many cups of lemon juice should they sell until they reach a tie?
Let me solve it using y and x
y = the sum they collect
The amount they collect
Not the highest value - but the amount they collect
Let x = the number of cups they sell
Which they sell
How much is y as a conjunction of x?
If y = - well, for each cup sold
They get $ 0.45 - if = $ 0.45 x
Number of cups
This is not the least amount they need
For a girl or not the least value that
They have to pay to run the kiosk
How much do they earn a point equal to each
A cup of lemon juice?
They need to collect $ 25
And to make a tie they have to collect $ 25
How many cups of lemon juice should they sell?
You must be $ 25
How many cups should they sell?
Well, put this equation
Say 0.45x should equal 25
We can divide both sides at 0.45
On the left side, we have x
We get x = - you output 25 0. 0.45?
= - they should sell exactly 55.55
Cup or 56 when I zoom in
55.5 cups refined
But we can not sell half a cup or supposed
Do not sell half a cup
If you answer this, he should sell 56 cups
Because you can not sell half a cup, I suppose so
If they must sell 56 cups to share the amount equally
Let us do this graphically
Again, we will be in the first quarter because
Everything will be positive
The price per cup is $ 0.45
Suppose they sell - that's it
Number of cups, x
That is the amount they collect
Let me follow the 5 multiples
5, 10, 15, 20, 25
In fact I will need even greater complications to get
The point we're talking about
So let me put the 10 multiples
10, 20, 30, 40, 50, 60
This is the number of cups
When they sell 0 cups, they will collect $ 0
This intersection y
y = 0
When they sell 10 cups, they collect $ 4.50
This is 4.50
This is 9
In fact let me follow this method
Let me just see the 9 multiples
To move 9, 18, 27, 35
When they sell 10 cups, they will collect $ 4.50
10 x 0.45
This is here
20 cups, they will collect $ 9.00
We can continue here
40 cups, they will collect $ 18
You'll see the tilt
The more you move 10, the higher it will be 4.50
This graphic representation will look like this
The line must be straight
And if you want to see a draw, a draw
It should be $ 25, and it is located here
Located here
The break-even point is $ 25 and is located here
Let me paint the line better than this
The line will look like this
If the break-even point is $ 25 - you'll be here - you see
They have to sell about 56 cups
As is clear, the way I draw out is not very accurate
But I hope it has given you the general idea
.